So great to be learning together Ashrei Raz
Teshuvah of the week and this week I'd
like to talk about an important topic and
that is if someone who is observing one
day of Yom Tov in Eretz Yisrael for
whatever reason are they permitted to fly back
on Yom Tov Sheni board a plane on
Yom Tov Sheni in Israel and return to
the United States? So first of all who
is observing one day? Generally speaking the accepted
position for generations at least from the time
of the Beit Yosef probably already to the
time of the Geonim maybe even earlier than
that is that a Ben Chutz La'aretz someone
who resides outside of Eretz Yisrael has a
misfortune of residing outside of Eretz Yisrael and
visits Eretz Yisrael for the Yamim Tovim has
to must observe Yom Tov Sheni. Now there's
a minority opinion that he only has to
observe one day but Lubavitch held from that
Rav Soloveitchik essentially held that so some of
his talmidim will tell their congregants to or
the talmidei talmidim to observe one day and
Rav Ovadia Yosef based on the Chida will
say that for certain people that there's either
it's their so the young young people young
unmarrieds who if they have the chance they
get the opportunity to get married they would
stay in Eretz Yisrael so they already can
observe which they should observe one day. And
so a group of people observe one day
so can they are they allowed to board
a plane? So I would think that it's
a terrible idea for them to board a
plane because the second they leave Israeli airspace
they're already in Chutz La'aretz because what's the
whole basis for the for the minority opinion
the Chacham Tzvi and the others that hold
that you observe one day in Eretz Yisrael?
They believe that it's a land-based issue. If
you're in Eretz Yisrael it's one day outside
of Eretz Yisrael two days. So as soon
as you leave Eretz Yisrael pashut that it's
no longer an
ordinary day and now it's Yom Tov Sheni.
So chol becomes kodesh. You can change in
the middle of the day why not? We
know the halacha is determined by where a
person's located. halachically for tefillah for tefillin for
all your halachic obligations wherever you are located
on the plane as well wherever you're located
you have to observe the halacha based on
where you are. You find this in the
Gemara in Shabbat on kuf yod chet amud
bet that says oh it's great to be
someone who starts Shabbat early in Teveria and
late in Tzipori. Tzipori is a higher elevation
Teveria is a much lower elevation about 200
feet below sea level about 200 feet above
sea level in Tzipori. So you're talking about
that based on where the halacha is determined
where you are. Even
if you're a resident of Teveria if you're
located in Tzipori you have to observe Shabbat
according to Tzipori. And if you are a
resident of Tzipori and you're in Teveria you
have to follow the halacha as is in
Teveria. So that's very very clear so wherever
you are located in the plane that's where
that's your location that's your halacha. So if
you once you leave Israeli airspace that's it
you should have the status of it's now
it's Yom Tov Sheni. That means you can't
use the bathrooms on the plane because it's
all you close the doors it's electronic. You
are going west the whole how is how
are you going to be able to handle
that? You have all the obligations of Yom
Tov the Yom Tov meal Hallel Musaf. How
how are you going to do that on
the plane? Okay I guess you could do
that on the plane but more than that
you should not be on a plane on
Yom Tov you should not put yourself in
a situation of being in on a plane
on Yom Tov. There's an obligation obligation of
v'samachta b'chagecha to enjoy the chag. How are
you enjoying the chag? That's a simchat chag
to sit on a plane and even if
you have a comfortable seat you have more
legroom still that's not simchat Yom Tov to
be in a plane like that. That's and
now you'll tell me well you can't change
status in the middle of the day. You
started the day as ben Chutz La'aretz as
observing chol you have to finish the day
as chol. No absolutely not. We find the
Gemara in Yevamot lamed gimmel amud bet that
speaks about someone a katan who reached physical
maturity he higia l'shteis sa'arot. on the middle
of on the middle of Shabbat. That's it.
He is Shabbat full-fledged Shabbat for him as
as a gadol even though it's middle of
Shabbat even though he started Shabbat as that
he's not a gadol now he he changes
status in the middle in the middle of
Shabbat so too on the plane you change
status. Begins a day one day changes changes
in the middle of the day. And and
so therefore all the rabanim that are that
are that I'm aware of will say that
you have that that's it. You change your
status on the mid-flight and therefore you should
not not not not take that flight. I
know Rav Shmuel Karshkaman said that's what the
Sefardic poskim will say. And
and and the Lubavitchers,
Lubavitcher poskim also who they say one day.
No, do not take a plane. Only is
one day only in Eretz Yisrael. As soon
as you leave that's it. So and I
spoke this past week to Rav Schachter and
Rav Willig they think you shouldn't board a
plane. Thinks it's a horrible thing to board
to board the plane and I've heard the
rabanim that that say no you don't that
believe that you don't that there's no obligation
to that that to go into Yom Tov
Sheni on the flight. It's only that when
you land then it becomes Yom Tov Sheni
then you have to stay in the airport
the rest of the chag. I hear there
are rabanim that that have that do say
that. I've heard that. I just wonder what
their raya is. I haven't heard any rayot.
What's the svara? What's their evidence for it?
It just seems to be very very weak.
I don't seem to I don't understand the
basis for it. And but even according to
those opinions let's say you have to stay
once you've arrived that's it. It's Yom Tov
Sheni. You can't go you can't that's it
for you for sure it's Yom Tov Sheni
once you've landed even according to this opinion
that I don't understand. But you have to
still but even according to that you must
stay in the airport. What are you going
to do? You can't take your baggage it's
just going to sit there in the airport
with with all your bags even if you
don't have bags you're just going to sit
in the airport. That's Yom Tov setting yourself
up to be a situation like that on
Yom Tov? What kind of a Yom Tov
is that with all the obligations of Yom
Tov Hallel Musaf with the simchat Yom Tov
with the fruit? That's just just seems to
be a horrible just seems to be a
horrible idea. I know there's is there's the
convenience factor and and pricing maybe better. But
still better spend the time in Eretz Yisrael
and bottom line is I think it's a
horrible horrible idea to board these flights on
the on the second day of Yom Tov.
Eretz Yisrael you're observing one day then for
whatever reason you're observing one day and that's
it you observe you do it properly and
you don't you don't get on a plane
on Yom Tov Sheni even if you're observing
one day in Eretz Yisrael. Wishing everybody a
great week full of bracha and beriut.